[Applause]
good afternoon welcome to the interval
and I'm Kevin Kelly low now board member
Senor maverick at Wired magazine I'll be
asking needles some questions I have a
handful and then we're gonna really open
it up to this crowd here so Neil is of
course probably one of the most popular
if not the most popular science fiction
living science fiction author today very
prolific and someone who's really been
instrumental and influential in I think
the course of our technological
innovations today and he has a new book
and we're gonna hear about it so Neil if
you would come out sure
[Applause]
so welcome thank welcome in the interval
you've been here before you made a
mistake of having me stand next to a bar
while you were introducing yeah so this
is the book the fall it's massive it's
an eel book it's an eel book has anyone
any of your fans ever come up to you it
said Neil could you make your books
longer all the time yeah because they
really yeah well I think I think part of
the one of the superpowers well they
don't say it that way they say well you
know what happened you know like I want
to know what happened to these people
after you know the last page so that's
effectively asking for for more I don't
know the I think one of the superpowers
that books have that is that people
desire now is being able to cover
something in great depth and breadth so
that's why that's why we have big
long-running
miniseries like Game of Thrones and it's
why we have big books those are the two
media that we have right now where you
can tell a story and convey a world in
tremendous detail so I felt heroic just
finishing the book just reading at all
you are I could imagine writing it it
was just sort of mind-boggling so are
you kind of like a person who does the
300 words a day some whatever that
minimum is yeah and are you still
writing in longhand and pen yes
so you wrote this book out in longhand
yeah I mean it's it's not I mean it's
it's more about steady work than doing
you monumental amounts of work I mean if
you think about it it's not a big deal
to sit down and write a few pages you
know
a morning if you do that every day or
you do it 300 days a year you've got
much more than a novels worth of
material after a year right so if it
just becomes a habitual activity then
generating lots of lots of pages is it's
just it's it's not as big an
accomplishment is it might look like if
you just suddenly see the entire thing
finished but my understanding is you
actually we're working on this for a
number of years over a number of years
well I had the idea a long time ago of a
kind of this general well first of all
I've been interested in in Milton and
Paradise Lost for a while so for a long
time I was thinking of trying to do a
other people are thinking of this too
it's not an original idea but but
Paradise Lost would make a great movie a
great subgiant action sort of Lord of
the Rings movie because that's kind of
how it reads there's these huge wars
between Heaven and Hell where they're
shooting cannons at each other and you
know it's it's super epic in scale but
Milton himself was a really interesting
guy he was a believing practicing
Christian from a Puritan background but
when he was a younger man before he went
blind he was sort of like an action hero
Puritan you know he would go around the
university with a sword and he'd get
into fights with the more Cavalier type
people and he went to Italy and wandered
around Italy during a time when a lot of
the English people he was going to
encounter there would be sort of
Cavaliers Royalists who would be you
know armed and and gunning for him so it
was kind of a swashbuckler and he he
went to Italy and he he hung out with
Galileo so he actually sought out
Galileo and
talk to him and then the end he comes
back to England and various interesting
things happen to him
they're there and he becomes a famous
blind Christian poet but so he'd be an
interesting study for a biopic right all
by himself so you've given a little hint
about the book do you want to is there
any way you can summarise it further
yeah well so a lot of my books are
actually multiple books combined into
white right so for example Krypton o
makan is a world war two book and a
modern-day book that are interleaved and
that's true of a bunch of my books so
this one is a high fantasy novel that's
embedded in a techno thriller and the
Technic thriller is about a guy who dies
and it turns out that when he was a
younger guy he came into a bunch of
money it was that was that my beer and
hitting them the mic sometimes that
happens when he was a younger guy and he
came into money for the first time he
was he signed one of these wills that
gives instructions on how to preserve
his body after he dies so he'd be
brought back to life and and then he
forgot about it because he didn't really
care it was just sort of a thing he did
on a whim but then he dies unexpectedly
and his family and friends find this
will sitting there like a time bomb and
they have to figure out how to carry out
the terms of the will and because the
the deceased is a billionaire they can't
claim that there's a lack of resources
you know they so he gets scanned the way
they do it is they scan his brain and
then later on he is brought back to life
in the cloud as a digital simulation of
a consciousness and there's nothing
there and he wants qualia he wants
something to be there i I've just made
Alvie very happy
in his favorite word no the he you can't
your brain has hooked up in such a way
that you know it needs it needs stimuli
it needs in these inputs and and he's
not getting any of that so he has to
create them and he starts to build a
world that he doesn't have clear
coherent memories of where he came from
just fragmented jumbled so memories and
so he begins to try to assemble a
coherent world out of that and ends up
building a world that's kind of like our
world but it's sort of a mash up of our
world with you know the Bible and Greek
myths and Lord of the Rings and you know
whatever was going through his head and
then other people start showing up and
sort of spreading out and populating
this world and that is the world in
which the the high fantasy novel takes
place and we know that it's a digital
simulation but the people who live there
don't know that it's as real to them as
this world is to everyone here raising
the question of is it just turtles all
the way down right right yeah so so Snow
Crash was talking about the Metaverse
it's kind of like a VR world this is not
VR this is actually a synthetic world
where there's no interface with the real
world right so so so there's there's a I
just said there's lots of talk is about
wills mortality deaths I wonder if in
writing this did you change your mind
about anything yourself but you're mean
did did they give you any insight in
yourself about what comes next about
yeah about that stuff the you know I
tended to be pretty skeptical of the
whole idea that the world is a digital
simulation because it seems a little
fast file but I I think I warmed up to
it a little bit during the course of
writing writing this one like you know
what if this world is
you know a simulated thing that came out
of a previous world which it's again
Turtles all the way down and so I play
with that a little bit but the I should
say another big influence was David
deutsches book the fabric of reality
where he gets into the topic of how much
computational resources would it take to
to make a truly realistic simulation of
this world mm-hmm
any kind of heads in the direction of
well it would pretty much take the whole
universe to simulate the universe and so
there's some some reference to that also
in this one of the things I've noticed
often kind of carries through allow your
books at least the more recent ones is
that there's a there's often a kind of a
gun-toting Idaho lien right-winger
character at least or some some aspect
of that and I'm wondering if that is
deliberate or just accidental well
there's not a I I do
enjoy putting in kind of people who are
who take action in a non-reflective way
because it's kind of the opposite of me
and a lot of the probably of a lot of
the people who read these books so
there's a little bit of wish fulfillment
and including characters who are like
that in these things the then there's
flashes of that and in fall but it's not
quite as prevalent as it is in in some
of my other writing books another common
thing that I've noticed is like the your
title here is that you seem to enjoy
titles that are either hard to say hard
to spell hard to punctuate yeah is that
deliberate the well I'm you know it's
wordplay it's the it actually became an
interesting topic
and when I was trying to decide on what
this was going to be called because
search engine optimization is becoming a
factor in what books art are called
right so so my first idea was to call it
fall and they were like oh that would
have been an awesome title 15 years ago
it's a terrible title now so because if
you start typing that into Google you
know it's not gonna lead very quickly to
your book so I said well how about
dodging hell because that's why I've
been that's why I had been privately
calling it to myself the whole time I've
been working on it they're like well you
know that's maybe a little too far in
the other direction and so I said well
how about fall or a dodge in hell and
eventually everyone kind of warmed up to
that and that's what we called it with a
semicolon
yeah well I'm told that the punctuation
is really playing havoc with yes with
searches and yeah so you a game of
Thrones fan yeah so as you heard there's
a lot of disgruntle among some fans
about the ending so endings are the
overrated or underrated well the I I
think the the dilemma is always you know
do you make an ending that that's tidy
and path so that the risk of having it
be not realistic because tidy Pat
endings you know they're satisfying but
it's not whatever really happens right
or do you have it be a little a little
looser in the way that real life is at
the risk of of having it seemed too
open-ended so you know I've kind of done
both
and in you know a few of my books I've
gone to some lengths to architect big
complicated endings that all kind of
substandard I haven't haven't done so as
much on the internet there was a joke
that if they had given you the task of
writing the last episodes of Game of
Thrones there would be two more seasons
where there'd be bureaucratic minutia of
having rebuilding King's Landing yeah I
didn't get that job I do yeah I do see
the in in that another television series
I sometimes see things that my initial
reaction is that I'm looking at lazy
writing but I don't know if it's I
suspect what it really is is the
showrunner saying such and such thing
needs to happen right you know 35
minutes into this episode or else and so
then everything has to be rearranged to
make that occur and so so that's I think
when you sometimes see a character
suddenly do something that's out of
character you know which I think
accounts for a lot of dissatisfaction
that people felt when with the the last
part of that TV series kind of rushing
it to a conclusion so speaking of
screenwriting you've written a lot of
books I'm not sure if any have made it
to the screen know what's the state of
that are there are there any news you
have any news on on the screen version
of one say I have news exactly but Snow
Crash is being worked on the Seven Eve's
is being worked on those are kind of the
two at the moment that we're like
they're active
projects in the world are you involved
in the screenwriting part I'm not really
like I you know I've got some meaningful
creative contribution or some other such
contractual language but it just it
depends on what the you know some writer
will get the job and then they have to
make up their mind what degree of of
interaction they want to have right and
so so it just varies I'm generally fine
with it either way mm-hmm
one of the delights in this book for me
was the the sections mostly in the
beginning where you have a discussion of
the near future and there was this idea
that we were entering into the world
where there was for every hoax there was
a kind of anti counter hoax that was
trying to flood it or disarm it and this
whole idea of kind of the the arming of
a weaponizing of hoaxes and making the
arms race out of that it was incredibly
well done and I think brilliant and it
feels like that's where we're headed to
is that something you've been thinking
about for a while well I wrote the the
chunk of the book that you're talking
about in sort of 2015 early 2006 oh okay
it was really patting myself on the back
for being way out way out ahead of
things and then when the election
happened I kind of went into a spiral
for a while because you know you made it
clear I was years behind not decades
ahead and so I actually ended up kind of
rewriting that I had written it kind of
as well here's the thing that might
happen isn't that you know isn't that
alarming and then I kind of had to
recast it as here's a metaphor or way of
thinking about what actually did happen
mm-hmm so it's more portrayal of
a way of thinking about how things are I
guess then prediction III think a lot of
science fiction writers have kind of
shied away from the near future yeah
because it's sort of gotten harder do
you and you did a great job with a
really believable version of the in the
near future
Thanks do you find writing with more
difficult to write 50 years ahead or 500
years ahead I think
well obviously 500 years ahead you've
got more leeway no one's gonna call you
to account but you do have to kind of
you are kind of operating in more of a
an unstructured future when you're that
far out you have to kind of you're
personally responsible for making up all
of it I guess you could say
whereas in you know more near future
thing you can kind of build on existing
kind of underlying infrastructure what's
your down so they both there are
different styles of writing require kind
of different approaches different skill
sets and then why mm-hmm so one of the
one of the areas that I've been
unsatisfied as a consumer science
fiction as Britta Klee in the Hollywood
version it's been the mere you universal
you dystopian aspect of science fiction
and that there isn't or very very rarely
is there a depiction of a future that I
want to live in right and number of
years ago you were interested you were
involved in the project to the
hieroglyph project which was trying to
remedy that by bringing some science
fiction authors together to come forth
with some positive desirable futures but
that was a number of years ago is that
still going on is that active did it
make any difference I don't know if it
made any difference but I'm I'm back to
full dystopian nice
[Laughter]
and what why why what what changed yeah
what changed the so the idea with the
hieroglyph project was to try to present
some specific so of iconic projects or
things that could be built that you know
that might have a kind of inspiring or
motivational effect and so you know I
wrote a story about a big tall tower
which actually is going to get published
as a separate little novella by
subterranean press I think next month
and as I'll find stuff to do it was hard
to get people to break out of that mode
and and and now you know I sort of have
this guilty feeling that I took my eye
off the the dystopian ball long enough
for for things to go horribly wrong so I
won't make that mistake again okay no I
mean the the you know I think what we
learned is that yeah so a lot of what
people are concerned about with the
current administration and so on is sort
of damaging the rule of law you know
constitutional checks and balances and
so on which is all true but the more the
deeper more underlying thing that's
happening is the erosion of the whole
concept of factual reality as a thing
that we can that we can work from that's
a it's something so fundamental that I
wasn't even aware it existed until until
it was suddenly gone right and so I've
been there's a book called a culture of
fact by barbara shapiro that i keep
pumping which is about how the idea of
fact
came to us because it wasn't always
there but at a certain point it kind of
emerged and the system of algorithms for
determining what facts were kind of
emerged and so she kind of explains how
that happened and and then what it
changes that it then created in science
and history and the arts and so on
so it's kind of a good news/bad news in
the sense that bad news is that for a
long time we didn't even have the idea
of facts at all and maybe the good news
is that it's possible to socially
construct that but yeah so it's a
fundamental thing that once you lose it
I don't know how you get it back so I
have one more question then we'll take
questions from all you guys kind of you
have many and better questions the the
another in this book another kind of
default accepted technology that is sort
of there without any introduction are
the smart glasses and which is kind of
an a a augmented reality version of the
world you you have a position of some
sort with magic leap
[Laughter]
how's that going what's our is the
project you're working on still
continuing yeah do you have enthusiasm
for smart classes in general just tell
us a little bit about that yeah so I
don't know the I think the iPad came out
less than ten years ago the iPhone is a
little older than that so the it's only
been that long that we've been going
around staring at little glowing
rectangles all the time and you know you
look at movies that were made in the
1990s let's say that are meant to be in
a high-tech environment and you know
people are sitting at these enormous
computer monitors that shockingly low
resolution screens and they're talking
on giant cell phones and it just looks
ridiculous right so I assume that that
we're all going to look ridiculous and
in other 15 years because the little
rectangles that we stare at all day will
have been replaced by something else and
my guess is it's gonna be some some kind
of headgear so the so so magically if
and other companies are working on that
and the the way I thought I might be
useful isn't trying to think about about
content and what you know what people
could do on those devices that was but
it was new and special to those devices
as opposed to a
re-platforming existing styles of
content so I have a little sort of
content or in a d-squad I work with up
in Seattle we released some tools some
sample code last year called the goat
labs developer samples that if you
downloaded and compiled it enables you
to populate your environment with baby
goats so and in order to do that you
have to there's actually a lot that has
to go right for that to happen at all
that was kind of the first thing we did
and we're working on a larger content
project that sort of a world building
project that I'm hoping we'll be able to
start showing the people in in the next
year or two so there's a team working on
actually generating some content not
just the tools but actually world or an
experience yeah started with tools that
we needed to have right in order to do
anything and then and there's more than
one team I'm just talking about my great
my little group okay yeah already and so
does it have a name my group or the
content Oh the content it's called new
found land okay it's a IP universe so we
we've trickled bits of it out on on the
internet already but the there's more to
come okay yeah great so I think we'll
take questions from the group
and maybe we'll start at the front and
then go to the back back and forth I
know Dave malts here you talked at the
very beginning about your writing
process mm-hmm what about your editing
process because you're gonna generate
pages upon pages you said 300 days a
year three pages a day that's 900 pages
several years going into this so how
much do you winnow down and how do you
approach that I I tried to proceed in
such a way that there's very little need
to to winnow stuff down so although my
books are long I like to think that
they're not redundant or there's not a
lot of stuff that that needs to be cut
out so it's just it's a there's a it's a
it's a commonly taught procedure that
you generate a huge amount of material
and then
and then winnow it down yeah I think
it's a terrible way to do it because
every time you you make cuts you're it's
it's it's a lot like writing code every
time you make a change you're you're
you're snipping internal connections
that will come back to just destroy you
eventually and sometimes it's obvious
but the ones that really destroy you or
the cases that aren't obvious and so so
it's better to just you know that that's
why I only write for maybe two hours in
the morning because well I learned a
long time ago is that if I go longer
than that that's when I add in a whole
bunch of garbage that it's not just
removable garbage it's garbage that's
like knitted together with actually a
good material so that I can't I can't
remove the garbage without actually
destroying the good stuff so so that is
my that's how I do that some yeah some
in some ways these are some parts are
kind of more modular than others look in
this case we're jumping back and forth
between two different universes so
they're them the modularity becomes an
easier thing in other cases it's not so
easy let's do one in the back is there
somebody in the back with the microphone
okay oh here this got on the front okay
we're doing the back next I knew so a
lot of this book has to do with the
utility and sometimes like necessity of
shared fiction or shared facts early on
in the book the barbarians in Nebraska
go all the way past like conspiracy
theories to just incoherent images and
sounds that they compel compulsively
consume yeah what do you think the how
far can this go
how Cerf how far can the erosion of
common facts go before it faces some
countervailing force I have the feeling
we'll be finding out
the the the big you're referring to is
on YouTube now I mean there are
algorithmically generated videos on
YouTube that no one knows who makes them
they seem to be aimed at children and
they just if you see one they keep they
keep coming so the algorithmically
generated stuff is a real thing today
the I think I I think people start
paying attention to facts when it's to
their advantage like you can't make them
like tediously lecturing them on on what
the facts are never works and people who
whether or not they're so of educated
people or are less educated people you
know are easily seduced by by by non
facts but you know it's something that
sounds satisfying that that gives a
gives them an emotional satisfaction and
they don't particularly care if it's
factually true or false so I think that
the only way to dial that back and and
redress that situation is to somehow get
into a situation where we're knowing
what is real and what isn't real
actually has consequences so I was I was
trying to figure out if there was a way
to deal with money like if you had like
it's a it's it's an old traditional
thing to you know to have a bar bed
right you know you're arguing about you
know some old piece of movie trivia and
you know I said well ten dollars says
you're wrong right and then that's the
point where you kind of have to deceive
and pay attention to what to what really
is and isn't so so you know maybe
there's a use for a blockchain after all
[Laughter]
okay in the back we have somebody there
thank you thank you my question is about
intellectual and ideological Walt
Gardens and it's kind of like something
in your work that's been really
important to me I mean burp lives and
then also an FM almost as like a series
of nested ideological kind of
intellectual gardens and I just want to
tie that to like the big five now and
Tencent because you're looking to see in
the economy you're seeing a lot of
people building incredibly huge powerful
valuable walled gardens mhm and I'm not
going to say I mean you kind of
predicted that on some level I mean
which would you see that going dystopian
or a utopian or I mean that's and that's
not even a great question what do you
what do you up I mean what do you think
about that look where do you see that
going I mean I can see birthplace
happening in 10 20 years cuz people are
so terrified so I mean that's that's my
question
yeah I mean you see it all the time in
in these efforts that the big five make
to kind of suck you into one ecosystem
or another and I think people are
getting fairly jaded and pretty
skeptical of any like no I don't want to
die from your app you know no I don't
want to sign up for your newsletter
leave me alone so I don't know the I
don't think that that the big five make
money in the long run by by dominating a
bombed-out dystopian hellhole right so
okay over here Pete yeah people I'm here
um I just wanted one quick comment than
a question but when you ask this
question about his writing style I will
tell you I was working under Kevin at
Wired when Neil did a story of following
the fiber-optic cable around the world
and it was a forty five thousand word
piece and I will say when you brought
the copy in I could not improve it as an
editor he was the cleanest copy I'd ever
worked with ever with any other writer
and I actually worked with a lot of
writers
so I will say you have something going
on there about your first drafts that
are uneditable well anyhow my question
is kind of a tricky one for for the kind
of long nut crowd here is one of the
things I love about your stuff is you
create essentially alternative
civilizations like Anna femme but also
seven Eve's I mean you're kind of
creating a world that makes sense
on so many levels and interconnects all
the technologies and philosophies and
economies and it just makes sense and
even your kind of baroque trilogy to me
was essentially one of the best looks at
essentially how we invented through the
Enlightenment essentially the Western
civilization that we're kind of still
working on now representative democracy
and financial capitalism all kinds if
we're better or worse a few minor bugs
so pretty minor bugs but you kind of saw
out a civilizational level what was
going on there
and I'm wondering to Kevin's point there
is it feels to me what the world needs
now is a positive vision of it how does
this civilization work that is emerging
here with biotech and climate change and
you know knew all those things that are
kind of spinning around people are so
freaked out about the future but it
feels that we need a civil z a clear
idea of what is gonna emerge the point
for century or beyond that will actually
make sense Wallace you ever thought
about that assignment yeah I don't know
I mean the thank you for those kind
words the you know people have tried to
write science fiction depicting a you
know but here's how I think everything
out of work like Heinlein was one of
those and and it can easily come off as
being a little pat and okay you know
here's my solution
you know go go set it up like this
everything will be fine
of course nothing ever quite works out
that way so man I don't know I think we
need to get back to you know some kind
of shared concept of reality and and
what's true and what's not so that would
be my first my first area of concern
like in a bigger still a lot of things
are getting better right like
objectively there's health and life
expectancy and prosperity and so on
you know by according to numerical
measures are getting better in a lot of
ways but then you've got you know anti
Baxter's right so it seems like there's
this in a radical kind of pushback that
can never be completely kind of overcome
so I don't I will not be able to fully
answer your question right now but but
thanks for that thank you
sounds like you might have some readers
though if you were to do that a positive
view of the future
so another any other so Alvey
okay somebody back in the new Alvey yep
the my expect yeah first of all thank
you for being here
and I noticed that in a lot of your
books attempt from a technological point
of view they're very prophetic and then
from a cultural point of view they take
a lot from history and I was wondering
could you just speak a little bit more
as to how do you decide what
pay attention to from a technological
point of view today and also what are
some cultural ships and how do how do
they influence your decision-making when
you're writing all of your books yeah
well I wouldn't I wouldn't look to me as
an example of someone who who pays
careful attention to technology in a
systematic way I'm very hit-or-miss and
so I I missed huge things like you know
like I ignored blockchain for a long
time and then suddenly it was big and
important and there's a whole bunch of
other things like that that I especially
when it comes to life sciences biotech
I'm I'm fairly fairly clueless about
that stuff so the the the cultural
historical stuff you know I read a lot
of history I like history that has a
good narrative cadence to it and so what
kind of history did you read for this
book neil well this book I didn't read
much history because it's this is not a
very historically driven or research
driven there was some of the Genesis
stuff the old gods of yore yeah kind of
almost you know Middle Eastern yeah
there's there's a number of of
historical religions and mythological
systems in which you see the idea of
Supreme Being creating the world from
chaos which is interesting because like
I don't know what the word is that
they're using in the original texts but
they seem to have this kind of weirdly
forward-looking notion of this this
abstract idea called called chaos right
like we have a technical meeting today
for what chaos is and chaos theory but
they seem to have a notion of it as a
thing that you could make stuff from if
you were smart enough if you're gone
right so you have X amount of chaos
yeah from chaos yes right and then you
then some have through some process
that's never really explained the
supreme being forms that into stable
stuff so that's the first thing that
Dodge has to do in this book is learn
how to do that but but it's a fairly
constant thing across some really
ancient religious traditions and so I
give a little shout out to my
brother-in-law
Steve Wiggins in the acknowledgments who
is a scholar of a place called Google
RIT which is a Semitic a city in what's
now Syria where a bunch of religious
traditions came together so if it's got
you can see elements of what became
Greek religion any Greek god whose name
ends in eus probably came out of that
tradition and it's got pagan stuff and
it's got the beginnings of the
monotheistic religions as well so so
that's a pretty interesting place to
study for if you're interested in old
old religions and mythologies and that
kind of thing okay Elvie alright I hope
I'm driven to this question by your
remarks about dystopia okay you're just
still being views currently yeah and I
hope I'm not just talking about
historical religion but I I understand
that religion plays a role in this book
and I'm very curious what you mean by
that and I hope it's not the historical
religion
well the this is kind of about it's a
little bit about where religion comes
from and and why people that people seem
to have a need for it and so it's got it
performs sometimes useful social
functions sometimes less desirable
social functions but but there does seem
to be a need for it and a tendency to
believe in it and there's a I was
interviewing Esther's dad at Town Hall
last year we talked a little bit about a
quote from from Freeman Dyson saying I
am a practicing Christian but not a
believing Christian
so the did you guys go to church no not
really okay so I didn't practice that
okay okay
anyway the so kind of what happens in
and this is a recapitulation of that
because everyone wakes up in the new
world with shattered broken memories or
no memories at all and and they they
begin to formulate kind of what we would
identify as religious ideas and begin to
practice religions in different ways and
so it's a little bit about the conflict
between two different powerful figures
in this world who have different takes
on how things ought to be organized and
there's dodge who's sort of more of a
pagan pragmatic figure who's surrounded
himself with what looked like pagan you
know
deities and then there's L who's a tech
entrepreneur who's enraged by how dodge
has screwed it all up
and like ll wanted to make a new
universe that got rid of the old legacy
cruft
of our world and you know yeah yeah Elmo
Shepard it's another prefix for for God
it's you know yeah well that this yeah
that comes out a little bit of the the
early Semitic religion stuff is that L
was originally one of several in a
pantheon and then people started picking
sides and so for example in you know in
the Ten Commandments it says you shall
have no other gods before me
it doesn't say there are no other gods
right right it never says that right it
just says you shall have no other gods
before me right so and that's another
actually asked by the light of your
world is that there are hierarchical
levels of God so there are gods and
their gods who make God's and part of
this god of religious stuff you're
talking about is the fact that there is
this bit world and there actually is God
who good people are making things there
they're creating land or creating
territory so they're they're performing
this God act which leads them naturally
and sometimes they're making other gods
that can make things so you have this
hierarchy ranking of gods and this this
recursive sense of it and so that's all
kind of reflected in some of the the
ancient myths which also have you know
demigods who are been made by other gods
yeah
Zeus is the kid of a Titan right who
then has sex with whoever he wants to
have sex with and
the those kids are all godlike to one
they're either out-and-out gods or
they're so demigods like Heracles or
whatever so that's sort of reflected yes
we have one more here than go back to
Esther okay back there please
sorry um my question Kevin asked him
bout where are you sorry oh you okay
Kevin asked about film and TV and also
about content with magically I was
wondering more generally how you're
engaging either as a consumer or creator
with uh with video games after playing
for example yeah so the I was a heavy
consumer sort of in the days before
everything went online multi-player and
then the first time I ever turned that
feature on I immediately got destroyed
by some random twelve-year-old and the
world changed for me and so so I almost
I was going to try to get in on on
fortnight because people I hurt her life
I heard people whereas of early adopters
talking about it I heard it mentioned a
couple of times I thought okay maybe I
can get in on this now
that won't happen you know I'll get in
I'll get good at it
early enough that that won't happen and
then like I waited two or three days and
then one of these I heard the
conversation between two of these early
adopters have you tried this yeah I went
on I just got obliterated by like random
twelve-year-old you know it's impossible
to learn how to play that game and so I
like missed this incredibly narrow
but day when daily yeah of time and so
so I I I do a little bit of game playing
just to kind of keep some awareness of
of what goes on in it what do you play
well lately I've been playing some
anthem which is a it's a cooperative
game so you can still be humiliated by
random twelve year olds but at least
they're on your side so that's the one
I've probably spent the most time with
lately I tried the new Red Dead
Redemption and - - yeah I got into a UI
problem where I said I had to remove a
bow from my saddle so I could shoot a
deer with a bow and arrow and it took me
half an hour to figure out the sequence
of UI gestures I had to make to reach
out with my hand and and remove this bow
and so that was frustrating there's a
cup for the magic leap one there's a dr.
gourd bortz game which is pretty
intuitive you know robots come out of
your walls and you zoom them and yeah
it's funny and reasonably so generous in
spirit I would say I mean it's funny
it's not just random violence and
humiliation
another question mister so the question
is vague I hope the answer will be
concrete okay just talk a little bit
about your own origin story what you
thought you were going to be when you
were six years old I understand I don't
know if you lived there but you went to
the University of Iowa Iowa State
University yeah the yeah I grew up in a
college town the it's a specifically a
college that's all about science and
engineering it's like it was a Manhattan
Project outpost there were you know kids
in my Boy Scout Troop whose dads we had
worked refining uranium for the
Manhattan Project and when you're a kid
wherever you grow up you think is normal
maybe you've had this experience and you
don't realize how weird it was until you
go other places and and meet other
people so so I had a lot of kind of a
science and engineering mentality sort
of baked in from the very beginning
so actually also I'll tell an anecdote
that sums up Ames Iowa in in my youth
okay so in my Boy Scout Troop some of
the dads came up with an idea we did all
the normal Boy Scout things like
Pinewood Derby and whittling arrowheads
and that kind of stuff but they came up
with this idea which was that one of
these guys worked in the AG engineering
department
he's the co-inventor of the cylindrical
hay bale and he took some corn seeds
that were as as close to being
genetically identical as he could get
they weren't cloned necessarily to like
maybe all from the same head of corn or
something ear of corn and he carried
them across the campus to the office of
another dad who was one of these
Manhattan Project guys and that dad took
it down to the sub-basement of this
building where the hot room was
so there's a like three-foot thick wall
of leaded glass with manipulator arms
and on the other side of it is
incredibly radioactive to stop and so
that dad took the corn seeds and put
them next to really radioactive stuff
for differing amounts of time and then
like painted them different colors too
you know the red ones had been really
exposed to a lot of radiation and you
know so on and so forth and then those
were handed out to us at the next
meeting of the the boys got through and
the assignment was to plant them and
cultivate these seeds and then after a
month we'd bring the plants and and
there'd be a prize given out for the
tallest healthiest corn plant and
another prize for the weirdest mutation
and this is all completely deadpan no
hoopla no sense of how weird this was
it's like yes one of the things you do
in Boy Scouts grow mutant plants you
know so that's kind of where I came from
and I so I you know I studied scientific
type topics in school but I always
reserved some hope that I might be able
to make a living as a writer as well and
so I just didn't study it because I
figured I could kind of work that out on
my own and so then after I graduated
from college I started writing books and
after on the third one I got very lucky
a whole bunch of things randomly fell
into place for me and I got an agent I
got an editor I was able to publish a
book and so so that's what I ended up
doing that was kind of Sue's never has a
real job
well I've had real shitty jobs like if
you mean like a career kind of half job
I've not
I had one of those other questions in
the middle here oh we somebody has okay
sorry hi I'm Kelly Juan sir
I guess lifting from Esther's question a
little bit I'm curious about the what it
was like when your first books came out
and what the reception was like and the
dialogues you were having around it
versus today 25 years later what it's
like now yes so the first book that came
out pretty much sank without a trace and
was pulped and does the name of that the
big you and then and then I wrote a
quite terrible manuscript because I
hadn't learned the the lesson I decided
I should have a work ethic because I
knew I'd gotten very lucky okay I'm
gonna do this eight hours a day and so
that was a failed experiment for the
reason I mentioned earlier and then then
I panicked
and I wrote zodiac in two weeks and and
then that got published and did okay and
then and then Snow Crash was the third
book and that got published and that
that so that was me kind of just seeing
what would happen if I wrote something
really weird
and you'd ended up being more successful
than I thought it would be so so now
it's just much more of a of a
predictable process it's more dialed in
the there was a lot of randomness to how
the first one's got got got published
and I think it's that's not saying that
they did it wrong it's saying that I
think when you're a publisher you're
basically placing a lot of cheap bets on
stuff with long odds to see what happens
and then anything that makes it through
that filter is is probably worth sinking
more resources into so
I was thinking about this yesterday when
I was trying to check into my hotel and
it took forever to check in because I
was standing behind shack in the
check-in line so Shaquille O'Neal was
consuming all of the bandwidth and I
couldn't get anyone to pay attention to
me so that's not an accident right
that's the publisher deciding that okay
it's a it's a sound economic bet to put
resources into promoting this book by
sending the dude on a book tour and you
know putting them up in the same hotel
as Shaquille O'Neal so you know it's
just it just becomes a more dialed in
and I'm I'm still in the like I'm you
know incredibly fortunate and and doing
well but but there are people making
tens or hundreds or maybe even thousands
of times as much as I do by writing
books so it's a it's a crazily
exponential kind of of space to work in
you know JK Rowling's is like the
wealthiest woman in the world or
something just from writing books you
know so there's there's always somebody
who's making ten or a hundred times as
much as you are or less yeah right right
right you may be that you may be that
person to somebody else right so it's a
really weird business that way so I
think we have worked okay yeah I have
another process question for you you
mentioned at the beginning that you
compose your dress long hands yeah is
there any kind of writing technology
that you rely on fountain pens or
mechanical pencils or is this any old
instrument will do I use a fountain pen
and just it's it's a very low friction
way to do it compared to a ballpoint and
they're kind of aesthetically cool and a
while ago I
I switched to using fancy paper because
I thought it would make me more sort of
parsimonious in my use of of space you
know but that didn't work so I I used
this fancy paper from Italy but even
though it's fancy you know like the
total outlay for all of the sheets of
paper that went into this book is
probably less than $100 so it's not a
strong incentive but generally yeah okay
got one more one more
all right hey yeah more processing so
what have you learned about creativity
it's just is it just something that you
know the more like writing like the more
you do it the better you get at it or is
it it is yes it's like it's it's much
better to think of it as being something
like cabinetmaking
or you know playing soccer right you
play soccer a lot you get good at it and
you can do things that other people
think are special I say this is an
incredibly bad soccer player or if you
you know it's just practice makes you
better at it and and just makes it
possible to generate material so I don't
have like exalted or kind of mystical
ideas about about how that all works to
be time for one more there's a guy over
on this side I want to kind of cover Oh
the bar can find the bar yeah this
should be good yeah so I kind of wanted
to come back a little bit to the project
hieroglyph stuff and positive in your
future uh-huh
it's always seemed to me like one of the
more beautiful stories or sets of
stories in this is sort of how we get
around kind of specific extension or
catastrophic risks like story is it
illustrate that mm-hmm and I'm curious
if you see other people sort of picking
up the torch on that use any other
projects that you're excited about does
it paint those stories or if you see a
future for project higher if they're
writing projects you know I'm not aware
but I wouldn't be I'm not your guy for
that I'm not a good follower or a
scholar of of science fiction but I just
saw some reference the other day to some
new movement it had a really cool name
it was like what proto peein that could
have been it yeah hey that's my word I
invent I use interpret okay that's great
I'm glad to hear this take it off it was
something like that it was a it was some
kind of movement in science fiction
writing you know that was it was trying
to head in that direction but it had a
cool name like that but I don't like the
the idea with hieroglyph was to come up
with buildable ideas that that such such
that there were clearly enough to find
that people could rally around them and
you know you could you could get an
organization full of Engineers and money
people and planners who all kind of have
the same notion in their heads of what
the end goal was and could work toward
that without an undue amount of
coordination and PowerPoint
presentations and meetings and I don't
know if we really got there the
I thought Cory Doctorow did a great job
with his contribution which is about a
3d printing thing on the moon mine was a
little probably a little too big the
20-kilometer steel tower and so the
others were more diffused they weren't
so iconic
necessarily so you know we will all work
on making our proto pian future together
yeah a way to work that in I wanted to
thank you Neil for for your
[Applause]
[Music]